taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
i taste buddies it's the taste bud
podcast i'm joe derosa i'm sal volcano
we're here with another fresh food
debate
yes i'm coming off a hot upset uh
oh my god biggest upset we've had yeah
and i don't know if we're gonna air
these in order but in case we don't
actually i won't even say just in case
for some reason this is a huge upset
there was a huge upset
where i was for the first time ever on
the history of this show
actually angry at the end of it as i
mean
dude i told you i knew it would happen i
knew it
yeah i was an oddsmaker what you're
doing right now doesn't help
do you know what i mean it doesn't helps
me and i also predict today
and this one by the way sometimes uh joe
and i will have
the idea um like weeks in advance and we
just keep a little note in the
background
sometimes it comes the next episode
topics come up on the fly that's what
just happened right now we're about to
record we're going to do a different
yes to a different poll yes and you
mentioned something and i mentioned
something else and we said
fine let's just run with it so this
battle was
just conceived one minute ago uh yeah
that is the truth yeah that is the truth
uh and i'm excited about it and it was
actually
born out of the episode that we're
coming off of
uh where we had the big upset and i'm
aggravated about
this came up during that and now we have
a fresh new house topic of cream soda
came up yes
and you said you despise cream soda
cream soda is the worst beverage that
has ever existed
okay uh i stand by that i will never
change my mind on that
it's disgusting it's worthless so we
said let's do an episode
which is the worst what do i think is
the worst now while cream soda isn't my
favorite beverage of all time
i enjoy it i understand it and i
have it from time to time granted much
more as a kid there's other
beverages i like do you believe you
referred to it as delicious on the last
it is delicious i mean you know do you
say a thing that you have from time to
time that you kind of like is delicious
that's because i'm i don't really i
don't really drink soda
okay you know like i don't really drink
you're better than the rest of us
probably
okay fine so uh but i what i
do all i had to come up with is what i
think the worst beverage of all time
right
right and i know what it is and i know
that like everyone
feels the same way and it is grapefruit
juice
grapefruit juice is i don't understand
how the industry as a whole i don't
understand how the grapefruit farmers
and their children are in the streets
begging as beggars because i don't
understand
how people eat grapefruit sliced in half
with a spoon i don't
understand how they have it in juice all
right i don't understand how they do
anything with it
before worst beverage worst beverage so
we're not asking you what the worst
beverage of all time
is because this might not want to be one
of those but out of these two which one
is worse
and the tweet is out okay let me tell
you why i'm gonna win
yeah please tell me please tell me first
of all grapefruit juice has nutritional
value
first of all uh some people like it in
the morning
but you know what i like you know what i
like about grapefruit juice yeah this
this feels
disingenuous do you know what i like
about grapefruit juice and i've eat it
yeah
you can mix it with so many things oh
you son of a
don't you dare do it i did don't you
dare did
i tell you you don't because you're
discrediting yourself didn't i tell you
before the camera started rolling i'm
gonna piss you off like i've never
fished
you have such a pair right now you can't
use
one argument against something and then
adopt that argument to defend your own
food in the next episode
i can i could do whatever i want but you
don't understand what you're doing
the people watching now are choosing by
the way
we i really would love you i mean we're
taste buddies here
but i really would like you to choose by
food but what you're doing is
you're slowly weaving a tapestry
of of of zero integrity and and
doubt that you're casting out on our
audience
because they don't want to hear you
chastise
vanilla for a cert for that reason and
then in the next
to serve yourself you then take the
thing you chastise vanilla about it and
you apply it to grapefruit
plus i love the flavor of grapefruit
juice i think it's a wonderful drink
i can drink it by itself i think it just
happens to be a bonus
that you can mix it with so many things
it's a bonus when you want to mix it
with other things i think it's just a
bonus that you could mix it with so many
things such a son of a gun man
it's not a bonus now why is it a bonus
for vanilla ice cream
maybe it is why isn't it a bonus for
glorious just letting you know
how it feels we got it okay but it is a
bonus
my favorite cocktail on planet earth is
a greyhound silver tequila okay
club soda grapefruit juice ah dude i
gotta be honest
grapefruit juice tastes like vomit
no way yes it does yes it does it tastes
and smells like vomit yeah
grapefruit juice and hummus i feel like
there's vomit in both of them you don't
like hummus
hummus is like at its best tastes like
like
like tasty vomit
come on yeah no no don't get me wrong i
love hummus but when they got to do a
bunch of stuff
get me wrong i love hummus what you
you're
you're talking on both sides of your
mouth over here
you just said it tasted like vomit a bad
hummus a bad hummus could turn me off
from hummus for months
a bed listen this is a thing you do on
the show can i can i please point
something out
you go often to this argument of a bad
such and such is the word of course sal
a bad anything is terrible
there's a bad version of every food my
point is that you
you could taste the hummus that you
think is delicious that i think is
terrible okay that's what i mean it's
like
not a bad hummus like an actually bad
hummus
but hummus in its purest form
has variations on how it tastes and
sometimes when it tastes more
humsy it it tastes to me like
like like like one of the ingredients
throw up even if it's the last
ingredient but you but then you just
said i but i love hummus
yeah because i because i do like certain
hummuses in
certain homeless flavors oh okay yeah
all right
so you'd admit that if a food needs
extra flavoring it might not be a great
food
no no no not at all
you just did no you just did yes
no no no that's that's true yeah it is
true not nobody's gonna have been saying
for a year that's not true
it's not true hummus i could no you're
you're taking your argument applying to
me all i'm saying is
all i'm saying is let's just take plane
hummus
i've had really good plain hummus and
really bad plain hummus
of course and the bad plain hummus is so
bad that i think it puts a little bit of
a cloud over hummus
on the whole one of my favorite foods on
planet earth contender for number one
spot is fried chicken
i've had awful fried chicken awful fried
chicken makes me want to barf
it doesn't mean that fried chicken isn't
still one of my favorite foods it's fine
then i can appreciate hummus
okay because letting you know that
sometimes hummus tastes like smells like
throw up
i think you use words that you don't
understand the weight of the words
okay i think you use words like love and
delicious
and i don't think you know what these
words mean sometimes oh i know what they
mean
i know what they mean listen to me
listen you are you are
if this was a court of law you would
have been disbarred by now
no way you cannot pick and choose when
to use an argument
for the for your own benefit it's
shallow just contradicted your own
argument no i didn't
i did it you did we both did we both
contradicted our own arguments
the reasons why vanilla and oreo that
you hated them
is why you said you love grapefruit
juice i just think grapefruit juice is
disgusting in and on its own
i think that i can't believe anyone who
drinks a glass of water i think anyone
who drinks it is like
probably an alien or have a lizard in
them i have drank a
full glass of ruby red grapefruit juice
first thing in the morning it is the
most
bitter to taste disgusting you could dip
grapefruit juice you could dip the tip
of your tongue like like a millimeter of
your tongue
and it sends a shock wave of acidity and
just
disgust all the way to the back of my
mouth i could drink i could have
one sip of grapefruit juice and
literally have
the worst heartburn ever for three days
straight sounds like two things
you don't have an advanced palate and
and your body can't handle grapefruit
juice
that's not the juice's fault what what
the flavor profile of grapefruit juice
the way you roll it over your tongue the
layers
citrus wonderful citrus citrus burst
it's not a citrus burst it's a bitter
burst it's a
citrusy burst no but citrus to me is a
beautiful a beautiful
it's disgusting before it has no
redeeming qualities
as a matter of fact when you brush your
teeth and drink orange juice
that tastes better than grapefruit oh
stop it yes it does
get out still orange is still breaking
through even though it feels really
weird it almost feels like the cousin of
grapefruit juice
but i'm telling you dude i'm telling you
i i know no one who's like i can't
you either love grapefruit juice or you
hate it most people hate it
no one's like i have grapefruit juice
from time to time it's your it's in it's
in your top five
juices grapefruit juice yes or no no way
it's in the top five juices you didn't
even say no
you went you you winced and then looked
down
it's in the top three juices i would say
when you go into a juice aisle
it's orange apple grapefruit
grapefruit's on the shelf before
pineapple
and i like pineapple juice don't get me
wrong take your head out of your hands
cranberry cranberry is the third juice
joe
all right fair enough see because i can
admit when i'm wrong
yeah cranberries getting off on a bad
start today
cranberry frank cranberry is the third
grapefruit is right behind it you're
seeing grapefruit before you see prune
i disagree i think grape juice comes
next
i do i don't i love grape juice and i
think grape juice is behind grapefruit
because i think grapefruit juice is
loved by the elderly
from sea to shining seeds elderly you
just called it
grapefruit juice you don't let's
discount all the elderly let them get
covered right
you don't you don't acquire a taste for
grapefruit juice until everything else
has fallen
off at the wheels oh boy that's what
happens at the end you're like you know
what i'm thirsty
and i just want something different i
want to feel again god damn it
that's what you do you're 90 and you go
i want to feel again what will make me
feel something and then you go oh
grapefruit juice is
going to make you feel human you know
why it makes it they drink because they
feel human because they're like i
remember what it feels like
to have a feeling a strong feeling a
feeling of disgust
let me tell you the thin ice you're on
today so far in this episode alone
ageism and racism you're knocking hummus
and grapefruit juice in the same episode
i i would tread more lightly if i were
you that's just me if i were you could
you imagine
starting with babe normally people start
their day with a grapefruit do you
imagine nothing else is in your stomach
and you drop in that battery acid in
your stomach to start the day
i've done it many days what is your
tongue and your what's your tongue
telling your brain when you touch it
when you bite a grapefruit and you go
this
feels right no but you'll have the salt
lick of an everything bagel like if
that's any better on your tongue
than grapefruit juice is come on buddy
come on i mean
come on you're talking about one of
america's most favorite foods that
everything
about what top five juices we're talking
the top five there's only like eight
juices
oh that's nice top five juice because
it's one of the only juices
mike look up top five selling juice hey
no no no no no no no no no no no
oh really the two
i'm just saying bud i'm just saying
you're gonna get slaughtered we're doing
i'm not gonna get
by the way before before before the
whole episode is about grapefruit juice
let's talk about the [ __ ] drink that
you're defending which is cream soda
who the f and you can bleep that
is eating a hot meal and goes i want to
wash this down
with something that tastes like a
milkshake but has no milkshake
quality i'll tell you and fizz i will
tell you who who
most of the united states most of the
united states is disgusting well
that's not what we're arguing and i'm
not necessarily i'm not
oh yeah okay you what i i just offended
all people you defended every you
offended everyone
most of the united states is disgusting
are you kidding me you just accused me
of treading lightly and then you wiped
out the entire nation
who the what is refreshing about a cream
soda nothing
nothing nothing frothy delicious cream
soda fizzing and bubbly on ice on a hot
day
it's disgusting about when you're having
a nice hot dog or a hamburger or a cream
soda no it's just
remember this remember it's like an
anchor man when he goes it's so hot milk
was a bad choice
that's what cream soda is nah that's in
your own head buddy that's not that's
not that's not popular
you're like one of these lunatics that
drinks that goes it's like 98 degrees
out you go i could go for a coffee
you're one of these people you know what
are you talking about right now
no but i'm not saying i wouldn't do that
but still here's the thing i'm not so
much defending cream soda as i am saying
that grapefruit juice is the worst
drink ever listen i know but i'm saying
cream sodas
if i wasn't even expecting to have cream
soda and i opened my fridge and somebody
brought cream soda over and there was
one in there i'd be like oh i'd be
delighted about it
if i saw grapefruit juice in my fridge i
swear to god
i would either give it away or i would
open it way before expiration
i would dump it down my drain to kill to
probably kill the freaking
corrosion that's happening in it and
then i would throw it away
let me just throw it away let me tell
you this i honestly i really feel like i
really feel like if i drink a proper
eight-ounce glass of grapefruit juice i
swear to god
i think i might throw up within the
first 10 minutes of drinking it
let's talk shipping shipping shipping
shipping i love talking shipping
i mean i want to talk station is what
you want to talk about not just
any old shipping shipping with ship
station and not just shipping but how
your shipping could be
more productive yeah if you're somebody
that sells stuff online
well you're definitely in the right
business especially now yeah more people
say
online shopping than ever sure uh and
that means that you got
your orders coming in you got your
orders going out and you need to ship
out fast that's why online sellers like
you need shipstation yeah
so this is basically going to aggregate
all the different delivery methods and
tell you what's the quickest easiest
most affordable way
to ship stuff out you can import stuff
from any sales channel
you can ship with any carrier you access
all the discounted shipping rates and
you automate it uh just about any
shipping desk you have
basically having like a a ship center
apply it to your own business it's
giving you yeah it's it's it's making
this
sort of thing cost you a much greater
less amount of time
yeah a much greater less amount of time
a much
it's it's making all my ship i'm gonna
ship you a bunch of dictionaries
yeah it's making shipping easier so you
can spend your time growing your
business is what i'm trying to get at
100 and it has a fully mobile app okay
and no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website ship station
funnels all your orders
into one simple interface and then you
manage the orders from there even from
your cell phone
ship more and less time just use our
offer code which is taste buds to get
60 free days a 60 free day trial that's
two months free
no hassle stress free shipping just go
to shipstation.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the page and type in
tastebuds that's shipstation.com enter
offer code taste buds
i was gonna say it the second time but
you know you jumped in make ship happen
i gave you that sal
do you like cereal yes do you like magic
even more do you like spoons the best
thing well i'm here to talk to you about
magic spoon series please go
guys like us ladies like us young old
all types of people like us okay they
have a hard time enjoying cereal these
days many of them
why you feel guilty sugar guilt yeah
carbs empty calories
a lot of your modern day popular diets
like the keto won't allow it
but that's where magic spoon comes in to
the mix
magic spoon per serving we're talking
zero grams of sugar we're talking 13 to
14 grams of protein
and we're talking only four neck grams
of carbs
140 calories per serving can you beat
that
it's keto friendly it's gluten free it's
grain free it's soy free
it's gmo free it's not free costs money
uh
but it's affordable we've got exciting
news magic spoon will be releasing two
amazing new flavors this month for a
limited time only
i don't know how they do this it's
incredible they've got now a cookies and
cream flavor
and a maple waffle flavor on top of the
old flavors which is
fruity cocoa frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon and i tried several of those
and i've also tried the blueberry and
they all
were delicious and they all taste like
real cereals they don't taste like diet
you know what i mean and if you're
listening from canada magic spoon now
ships to canada
so let's get let's get to the mate the
crux over here i want to get them to
discount
you're going to go to magicspoon.com
taste buds
to grab the new limited edition cookies
and cream and maple waffle
or a custom bundle that you could pick
out of cereal to try today
be sure to use our promo code tastebud
to check out to save
five bucks off of your order the offer
is now good anywhere in the u.s or
canada
but only when you use our code at
checkout that's magicspoon.com
buds with the promo code taste buds
remember get your next delicious bowl of
gluten-free cereal at magicspoon.com
taste buds and use the code taste buds
to save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring the episode
but listen but that's your body that's
you can't handle it
i'm talking about taste versus taste
cream soda is disgusting
you know how many times i believe sodas
even sounds delicious it doesn't
nobody ever said they don't go together
cream
soda those are two different ballparks
it's like going
hey give me a ham soda right now no no
they don't go together no that's
soda's supposed to be sweet
they go together as evident by cream
soda being around and thriving
for about a hundred years when did cream
soda was invented
cream soda uh is a sweet soft drink
generally flavored vanilla
the best flavor yeah listen based on
go to wikipedia when was it invented i
want to see the year cream soda came out
in this country
1852 yeah yeah
they knew what they were doing back then
thriving for 170
years or you could say food was [ __ ] in
1852
and they made a bad soda people talk to
brown
people are clinging to this is the
confederate flag of sodas
that's what this is keep clinging to a
pointless history
okay i i mean dude i mean 170 years and
it hasn't gotten phased out
you're interested and that's the only
way it should ever be served by this
jackass and a bow tie
that's on the screen right now have you
ever gone to um
universal studios yes have you gone to
the harry potter ride yes have you ever
had a bean
a bean beer or something butter beer a
butter banana no it's basically creams
and i would it's basically spiked cream
soda and it is it is
delicious now listen to me listen to me
if you're talking about a cream-flavored
drink that has alcohol in it
like a white russian for instance i'm
all in
but i'm talking about a cream soda
period
you're insane joe why am i insane
to even have this debate and put cream
soda
which is an iconic flavor of soda
against
grapefruit juice you you just you set up
easy wins for me
a and w i i i associate a and w with
root beer and cream soda
specifically and maybe maybe a burger
but like
even an a w cream soda you say that my
mouth starts to water dude
i mean but also you gotta get heartburn
from a sip of grapefruit juice i don't
understand the mechanics of yours most
people
most people want to kill grapefruit
juice oh stop it i swear to god
oh stop it you buy big grapefruit tell
me what your grapefruit juice came out
yeah you want to talk about going strong
well
wait you buy grapefruits do you buy
grapefruits sometimes you do
and you cut them how do you eat them the
grapefruit originated in barbados
now you're now you're insulting the fine
people of barbados
uh as well on top of this it came out in
the 17th century
it's going way stronger it's a fruit
it's a goddamn fruit of course it came
out that came out when god came
it's a wonderful fruit it's a wonderful
fruit kept tom hanks alive on that
island
you think he was fine you think he found
a cream soda tree i would be dead if i
got cast away and it was only
grapefruits
17.50 this is when it doesn't know if
it's a melon or an orange it's
it's like too big it's like it's too big
to eat in one serving for one person
it's too much too much acidity and
bitterness you put a little sugar in a
grapefruit
oh you s no you don't put it no you
don't
if you put sugar on a grapefruit you're
defeating your whole entire argument
because that is changing the art because
it's so bitter that you need to put
sugar on the
argument is not going down in flames i
will tell you this right now the
argument number one is not how do i eat
grapefruit it's grapefruit juice which i
will drink without adding sugar sugar to
it but you also add sugar to it
no i said i will drink it without adding
sugar to it i never add sugar to it
i also will eat grapefruit in a fruit
salad and that doesn't have sugar added
oh i hate when it's in a fruit salad and
i think it's a regular orange and then i
bite it that's the only time i have to
ever ingest grapefruit is when i'm
tricked into it
in a fruit medley look at the beautiful
color of it it's gorgeous
oh god no one buys it gorgeous everybody
has anyone ever said like
oh you know what to make this taste a
little better throw a little grapefruit
in it yeah
have a tequila with club soda and put
some grapefruit juice in it some ruby
red and you tell me it's not the most
delicious drink you've ever had you
don't have to i can tell you right now
it's not the most delicious
it tastes like like if vomit was a juice
that's what it tastes like grapefruit
consumption has
plunged by 70 oh my
in 1976 the year i was born by the way
at the height of america's love for
grapefruit that's how long grapefruit
has not been
in vogue okay they have moved on it's
been 43 years
you look up creams fruits were more
popular in 1976
few fruits were more popular than
grapefruit
since then however fresh grapefruit
consumption
has plunged by 7-0 70
and total grapefruit consumption which
includes the processed kind
used for juice has tumbled to almost 80
percent
eighty percent okay what i mean
i i don't have to even have the argument
for you just google your
love of just google grapefruit i just
read what it says
hello everybody uh thanks for uh
listening to taste buds
we have uh to talk about a sponsor of
ours called headspace
i am a basket case most of the time i am
neurotic person
i worry i maybe got it from my
grandparents best down to my parents
but i uh think i'm always about to die
way to pass the buck
yeah i mean the blame game is a tricky
one as any good therapist will tell you
yeah
that's right you don't want to get in
this head you know what i'm saying but i
have found meditation to actually truly
be something that helps me in my life
and headspace is just that it's a guided
meditation app
it's really easy to use if you join
using the taste buds promo code you're
gonna get a free month
which gives you back access to their
entire library a free month you could
try it
100 times a day for 30 days straight and
see if you like it
yeah and i like uh headspace in
particular because
number one it's helped a lot of people i
know which is great but uh i just like
the variety of stuff they offer i like
especially that they have that
three-minute
sos meditation where if you're really in
a jam
like yes which i use all the time or if
you need help falling asleep which i
often do
uh you know i mean sometimes uh you know
headspace provides a service for me that
it's like
hey maybe you don't go to sleep to the
stephen king audiobook tonight
maybe maybe you do something that'll
give you some better dreams
this is what meditation can do right
reduce stress improve sleep boost focus
just improve your overall sense of
well-being um
it's backed by 25 published studies on
its benefits 600
000 5 star reviews and over 60
million downloads so obviously this is a
proven track record
you deserve to feel better headspace is
meditation made simple go to headspace
dot com slash taste buds that's
headspace dot com
slash taste buds for a free one month
trial with access
to the entire library of meditations yep
that's it
do it for headspace do it for you
you got stuck there now you see what you
did you went out on a limb and you just
started saying some
some you started making up slogans on
your own you got brash
you got real brash at the end we were
going smooth and then you said i'm going
to take the bull by the horns and i'm
just going to start throwing out slogans
like you could do better than every
advertising agency
people have conferences about about
slogans and you were like i'm going to
take the reigns
and you said two and the third one was a
charm and we came to a screeching halt i
want to say something to wrap this up
yes
if we were on a limb i with all my being
would want to push you off of it and
watch you
fall down to hurt yourself somebody
needs headspace but i would listen to
headspace
so i didn't do that and instead i just
wish you well
on your part of the limb so you just go
to your part of the limb
and i'll stay on mine and we'll both
listen to headspace headspace.com slash
taste buds
still make cream soda is what comes up
when you google cream soda
because somebody wants one yeah because
somebody goes it's not the depression
anymore do they still make that
[ __ ] or can we drink good sodas in the
last 40 years
80 80 look up cream soda sales mike
please
cream soda sales i want to see figures
how do we find cream soda sales i got to
tell you right now this is how much
cream soda is better
not that one's better than the other but
the grapefruit is worse but this is how
much because we're talking right now and
i
am like i can't wait to get my hands on
a cream soda
like i want to go right now and have a
cream soda right now
okay well just remember this was the
drink that at the top of this thing you
said
you enjoy it from time to time you know
delicious i don't drink soda like that
now you're saying now you're saying you
want to go have one right now
that's how much you're saying you're
switching it's not my number one soda
anything on sales dr pepper and root
beer i'd say are my two number one sodas
if i had chews
i love dr pepper which does have a
creamy flavor to it in a way
okay i love root beer which is in the
family of a cream soda it doesn't make
sense while you're with the spice cream
sauce because it takes away all the good
parts of the root
root beer tastes like if you took cola
and
moved it in the direction of cream soda
before it went too far
cream soda is you took it way too far
and now it tastes like cream it's gross
would you ever pick a creamer up at a
coffee shop and drink it
yes i have that's insane why cream is
delicious you would drink you drink a
creamer out of this little like a little
shot
in my lifetime that's that's disgusting
i mean i bet you everyone has
that's just i haven't i i bet you
everyone has i haven't you as a kid you
never opened a creamer and drank
no no who does that everybody
who does that hold on we got some guests
you ever open a creamer for a coffee and
just drink the cream
like the half and half or something like
that chrissy d yeah
one of the biggest animals i've ever
known in my life
just an uncivilized beast
i mean come on nevertheless he's a human
being
like barely with his own clearly with
his own palate and his own experiences
so he's drank it all right let's go to
the polls
we can't you're gonna take a hard tumble
and another thing i just want to say
before this ends is
you can detest cream soda but the fact
that you think grape
fruit juice is is not worse
i know i get that you don't like cream
soda and you do like grapefruit juice
but man what an on hill to die you're
going to get you're going to get dem
that's what this show i understand but
you are going to get a drubbing right
now
all right you love that word you love
this word drubbing
you bring it up a lot you bring it up a
lot let's see what the people had to say
all right we got
just under 3 000 votes in okay and uh
we have a winner this is the humble pie
segment yeah somebody's got to eat
something i could already tell by your
tone that you won somebody's got to eat
something i can already tell
you keep running away with this like if
you want to keep
defending don't get so excited we got
two more to do today okay
here we go we got the worst beverage
after about 3 000 votes
you got winning aka losing because it's
the worst beverage
grapefruit juice would you like to take
a guess on the percentages
i'm going to give you i'm going to be
generous i'm going to say 80 percent
no it did come close than i thought it
is 65
35 which is a wallop though 65 35 is a
wallop
it's five more percent i one and i
completely doubled you okay
fine fine it is a okay it's a would you
call it a drubbing
a wallop and a wallop okay fine let's
see the comments
15 comments here wait
society considered cream soda the worse
it's the purest sweetest soda out there
i don't know
no no no no it said what society it says
weight society no but i think you tried
to write what i think it's a typo
oh oh i see what society considered uh
cream soda is like weird
ice cream soapy water with added fizz
yes there you go beyond odd it boggles
me well that's what that's what you said
yep
that's my vote for winter so far sour
cream soda
are you drunk how do you not like it no
see they don't understand
loves it they're thinking i'm asking i
hate both of these but which one's worse
i think they think well you told them
it's the food debate with us
how do you not put ginger ale here
because that's not what we're talking
about
somebody goes are you talking about
grapefruit soda no it says juice it says
grapefruit juice
uh they're both so terrible in such
different ways
i guess grapefruit juice because it kind
of resembles resembles sauvignon blanc
that's my favorite so far that's the
best one cream soda is great can't go
wrong
never drank these before but grapefruit
juice sounds horrendous
grapefruit juices is 20 20 as a beverage
very funny that's good too very good
meant to put cream soda is the best
grapefruit just suck a lemon or
uh for how sour it is oh here
i love grapefruit juice with tequila
it's called a paloma yes it is
grapefruit juice is an abomination
though cream soda isn't much better
never
listen to this lunatic never drank these
before
but grapefruit juice sounds horrendous
who's never tasted either of these i
know
my cousin once said that cream soda was
better than toys
[Laughter]
that might be the winner that might be
the winner
with or without alcohol without that's
why we said it that way
uh great cream soda a huge pregnancy
craving for me grapefruit juice you said
is the 2020 as a beverage that's pretty
good
that other one's pretty damn good though
there's a guy with q's picture
here we go a guy that wrote never had
grapefruit juice but it sounds
disgusting i don't understand i got one
dude it's not even close grapefruit soda
oh he brought soda grapefruit soda
tastes like what's in a battery
[Laughter]
that's funny garbage fruit makes garbage
juice
oh boy i'm getting pummeled on this one
jesus god
love them both especially together seth
herzog our friend writes
uh grapefruit juice is gross
cream soda is delicious grapefruit juice
is actual
poison yeah i saw that both horrible
drinks well hold on grapefruit juice is
god's nectar conversely
there you go grapefruit juice can make
opiates hit harder cream soda gives you
diabetes
i like that one
how do you not like cream soda because
it because i don't
cream soda is and then the barf faces
all right babe i mean all right i lost
yeah who's our winner for choices i'm
going to vote i'm going to give it to
my cousin said it was better than toys
yeah i agree that was really funny my
cousin once said
cream soda was better than toys what's
the name shout out to
vitali fan and you can follow vitali fan
at n-e-s-b-i-t-t-97
all right buddy i'll tell you what i
still love you
i love you too plugs it away
i'm getting pummeled today man all right
also pat walsh and i debate and review
movies
it's called we'll see you in hell uh new
episodes on patreon.com
wsyih podcast and then uh
uh the back catalog is wherever you get
your podcast
yes salvocanocomedy.com for any of my
dates
uh impractical jokers and in practicals
dinner party and mission
in uh misery index are all on the air
but uh check out
uh my other podcast with chris stefano
called hey babe
also where you find this podcast and uh
that's it
we will uh we'll see you next week taste
buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds better put on your
boots make sure they're laced up
what does that have to do with it
[Music]
you